hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft apparently
there was a big nether update I don't
know I didn't know that this is coming
maybe some people did but I'm just as
clueless as everybody else unless you're
not clueless and then you know and then
I'm just an idiot and I don't know so
I'm gonna find out I'm going back it was
last played in version who you are on
version me can I get backup in case you
create a backup of course create a
backup I did so much work I made a farm
and then I dug up four diamonds I guess
I didn't think of that much work Oh new
recipes oh I feel the view is all messed
up what did they do to my game is this
the same I don't know if this is
actually the same or any different how
would I know
feel the view normal they change what
normal was that's not normal don't you
[ __ ] ok well oh you're gonna make me
watch you die oh well that's a good
start and that's a good sign that means
that we're on the right track believe it
or not I'm gonna leave your sack because
I don't even want to touch it I'm gonna
go into the nether before I do that I'm
gonna find some food because I don't
have any food and I'm gonna need food if
I'm gonna go into the nether I don't
care if it's not really all ripens I'm
hungry I'm sure that there were a hole
but what my seats go okay I'm sure that
there were a whole bunch of other
changes that were made to the game but I
really don't know what they were I don't
even know if this update was already out
and it was in other versions of the game
because this is the Java version of the
game I don't know a lot of things and
I'm not gonna pretend like I dunno I'm
going to pretend like I don't know so
with that I need to go make some food
and then I can go into the nether and
then when I go into the nether I can see
all the new stuff unless I won't see any
new stuff because nothing new would have
been changed you know what I mean do you
know what I mean you probably know what
I mean is there any other reason that I
need to keep wheat besides making bread
I don't know but then again a lot of the
things that I don't know have often
gotten in the way of me doing things
that I do need to know I don't have
enough box I will make more box
bam box baby is it kidding dork I might
as well put this in my home I don't know
why I haven't moved in anything into my
home I still haven't put it pulls out an
ende what are you doing dude dude box
I sleep with box ok box put this in a
logical place for Boggs Boggs ok I'll
eat my food where is this dude is he
underground is there still that
underground dungeon that I haven't dealt
with that I really need to deal with
what I haven't dealt with it yet fair
fair's fair
no don't no not again no don't that
that's not natural that's not how that
works why do you choose to die oh god no
the air conditioner that's been loud
this whole time I'm sorry I'm really
sorry about that I didn't mean that
that's very poor quality on me that's
bad youtuber in me ok so this doesn't
look any different I was told that this
was going to be different I was told
that they were going to be chained water
you I was told that this was going to be
a little bit different and that they
were going to be new elements in here
new materials new enemies new structures
new everything do not tell me I swear
God please do not tell me I have to
restart my game to get the new nether
maybe I just need to break my portal and
then rebuild it and then it'll send me
to a new nether that's the answer we all
know the answer I don't know what this
is gonna do
I've never taken down another Porter
before I'm assuming that this is how
this works I take this part the nether
portal goes away
bring it back and then I see a new world
it is exactly the same world I was told
there's gonna be do i if I if I I swear
I'm gonna go look No
[Music]
No
now
okay because I've already explored that
part of the nether I need to go get new
nether because apparently the nether
that I have already explored isn't good
enough and in order to get the new
nether I will have to make a new nether
portal I'm assuming or explore in the
area that I have before up to 16 chunks
away I don't know how far 16 chunks is I
don't even know how far to one chunk is
because I don't know what a choke is
what I assume can be done is if I go and
this is me using my galaxy brain if I go
and I take the time to mine the new
obsidian and I bring that obsidian up or
keep it down and I create another portal
a new one it'll spawn me in a different
location because I don't know if when
you make a nether portal you go to a
completely different location or if you
go to someplace that's actually adjacent
to where you put the nether portal that
you just put I don't know what's true
but I'm about to find out so I'm gonna
go get more obsidian I need 12 beat 10
right I wasn't paying attention I'm
gonna go get 10 pieces I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna mama I'm gonna make a new
portal cuz all I need to do is get
another so it's an experiment worth
having and hey I'll even put it farther
away even though I got that really nice
Lava Falls those you know hey I got
plenty of this so I'm gonna use it it's
time for the time lapse you know how we
do hit it baby
it's fine
[Music]
and three two okay
this might count a bit but I got there
ten pieces and with these ten pieces I
can now make a new portal but it's not
gonna be enough I don't think just to
make a new portal that is in the same
area I want to hopefully make it in a
completely different area so maybe it
would be better if I actually make it
down here because it's cool the idea I
like it it's it's something interesting
I think I think it might be fun you know
redstone hi how you doing what are you
doing there I'll leave you there you'll
help power this bad boy I'm sure that
that's how that works
all right so I'm making this down below
so it should be somewhere different
maybe we'll find out hmm I'm ready
please don't leave me
how many of you knew that was gonna
happen how many of you knew that was
going to happen and you did nothing to
stop me from doing set action licks Ian
did you know did you know that would
happen because I didn't how could you
how could you I'm not actually crying
animate like some tears in or if that's
too hard just slapped me in the face I
don't care okay so you suck so what I
just
Oh me I'm sorry I don't get the new
nether I don't get it I don't get the
new nether because I'm not good enough
for it my Lava Falls is underwhelming my
farm isn't producing my well isn't
actually useful my house doesn't have a
roof and my nether portals lead to the
same gosh darn place is that what I'm
supposed to be understanding about what
I've been doing here because if I have
just yeah what do I have to do I would I
explore the nether and just have to run
no I don't want to do it I don't know
how to start a new world I literally
just got done another oh okay fine I'm
gonna stop being a business Lucien's
censor that I'm gonna stop being a
whatever lick seeing said and I'm gonna
suck it up okay here's my reasoning
because I could venture into the nether
deep enough to spawn the new area but
then I would have to run there and back
to get anything that's interesting in
the nether constantly or I could pack up
all my stuff here and then go to a new
area but that would be exactly the same
as starting a new world and I don't know
if I'm gonna encounter any bugs because
it said
it's fine I'm not a baby look at all
that I want to see that Oh see that fine
we're going popsicle 2.0 look I there's
no other way all right
there is another way I'm too stupid to
figure it out either way I couldn't
possibly do it this is the lush oh oh oh
oh are you barbecue I mean you know lik
seein cocoa beans wow this place is dope
this place is sick nasty look at these
thick trees what is that a squash
where are you Mel one what is a melon
doing in a jungle I don't understand the
mechanics of that but I don't mind
that's awesome all right we're starting
over and you know I feel pretty good
about this I got a new biome I got a new
start
the last level didn't love me it didn't
love me the way I deserve to be loved
which is intensely and passionately and
thoroughly so this level I can tell is
gonna embrace me with all the love in
its branches cuz I I feel one with the
jungle I feel at home in the trees we
are all children's of the forest after
all and nothing can stop us from getting
in touch with our roots yes this is the
place for me I can tell the hard-nosed
and the soldiers and I am biding time no
Lexi and just come back if anything
interesting happens
how am I gonna sleep I don't have any
sheep I don't have any wool
how am I gonna make a bed oh my god do
anything whoa isn't deep new recipe I
unlocked a boat
a bamboo bamboo die I should have shown
you I that's not enough to make up bad I
made a horrible air roar ah I'm dumb
alright but it's okay it's alright I
just need to get out of the jungle the
jungle so darn good alright whatever
I need to get out of the jungle because
it's just getting too much I just
executed what is that it looks like a
spooky forest what is over there what am
I looking at I'm in water
what about is that bamboo it's not just
the oceans of Bemba it was bent bar look
at all this bamboo oh there's so much
bamboo oh my goodness what do I do with
bamboo can I do anything with bamboo
stick
I can turn bamboo and a stick that's
useless what do I need to do that for
that's dumb that's dumb and it should
feel dumb
I need sticks why there's so much bamboo
fire wait a minute wait no hang on what
stop stop what are you doing please
don't I don't know what's happening here
netherrack so what nether portal just
appeared out of nowhere is that what I'm
supposed to believe just yeah what is
this magma block what does that even
mean
well okay then I might be able to make
another portal right here but what what
in fresh hell alright I guess I'm
building my base here
okay let's at least get stone tools up
and running okay I just chucked my this
go away please okay so I need iron
that's really all I need because I'm
wondering if there's there's lava
already there if I can get enough iron
just to make some buckets maybe
I don't have to dig it out maybe I could
just like place water on top of the air
grab lava from the bucket place it and
then go
it is almost night I am almost to die
sheep you will die
that's three that's all I need to do
okay I'm gonna go back I'm gonna make a
bed I'm gonna go sleep and we'll come
out on get some ayran and then we're
gonna see if we can get to the nether
record time what is it uh yeah here we
go place it down place it there we go
okay we're sleeping it's day I'm stuck I
can't okay I need to find iron okay so
nothing changes until I get iron why how
is it still on fire I might as well just
start digging I guess mm I hear that
I'll get definitely something nearby
sounds like they're right here where are
you Oh buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
fatty okay buddy buddy
oh no buddy buddy know but you know but
you know buddy Oh God all right we're
gonna there's iron right there you fools
you've fallen right into my trap okay I
need a little more I definitely need a
little more no there's no way there was
just a one really it was just the one to
the spar sister iron look is a man who
once had 16 buckets
I'm not gonna tolerate having any less
then it's several dozen okay I have
standards and I will meet those
standards this this
what I've always been talking about this
is what I was discussing all yeah this
is what I was discussing previously this
is what I was speaking about at length
this is in fact what I was articulating
my thoughts in regards to this is the
stuff this is the quality stuff this is
the very nice stuff I've got 17 all
right you guys are about to see amazing
things things you never thought you
would see but you are in fact seeing
with your eyes you're about to be wowed
and amazed actually just in case this is
my home after all I'm just gonna put a
door on this home all right
yeah okay that's that's fair and then
I'm gonna put a door there okay you know
no do you think that's what I want do
you think what I've always wondered yeah
that's that's good yeah that's good
thank you for that yeah it's good let me
place my stupid extra furnaces so I can
make this go faster but I'm not going
fast because I'm discussing problems
that I'm having give me half of you oh
you're almost done anyway because I was
wasting so much time yabbering on about
my own issues yeah whatever
all right we'll make a bucket make two
buckets I'm gonna make an iron pickaxe
and you're gonna be quiet
all right cool good I need to make up
how do I make a box is it just a square
no that's that is it is it like empty
around yes box and you're there no I
can't hope and you boxes got open I
forgot about that okay all right so
watch and be it's nighttime I know I
didn't close my door to the mines
probably fine all right so I've only
really got one shot I need to make flint
and steel I didn't make I'd be 20
I don't have any gravel does that gravel
I don't know what gravel looks like it's
gravel definitely that's definitely
gravel yes I got one
it's a serendipity if ever there was
serendipity I'm not a hundred percent
sure what serendipity means yes there we
go
okay I can't believe this is going to
work I actually don't know if this is
going to work but I can't believe it if
it does work can I please just it's
gonna be risky no put out the fire
please put out the fire how do I put out
the fire okay do not put out the
can you mine it with gold can you Maya
with gold can you do with gold you can
dig it out but you can't my okay is
there one piece of lava I just needed
the one piece of lava Oh
magma no no no I just
I literally just needed the one okay
alright you know where there's a
sunshine there's a rainbow I know I get
on a ladder it's fine it's fine it's
fine this is fine you know for every
challenge oh there was right there
perfect great good i-it's not digging it
it's just annihilating it I lost it I
didn't see maybe you can mine it with
iron I don't know how would I know that
did I try it no let me try it it's
probably the answer's no but
what stop dying okay I didn't get it
it's fine I just need to go find lava
that's all I need
that's all I've ever needed oh okay
yeah yeah if you could stop that'd be
great but this is what I needed this is
all I needed
okay so I've only got one shot at this
so to make my shot better I'm gonna put
this here and here cuz it's one in two I
go one poo I go one poo you know what I
mean I give a day you know maybe the old
three far alright so I sleep I do not
pour lava on my bed I was about to pour
lava on my bed here we go here we go go
ahead and put it there's no harm in this
there's nothing else no more damage it
could possibly do so all I gotta do is
three right here and then four right
next to it and it'll be hope oh wow and
then all I need to do okay me and my
buckets we're going in
[Music]
this is the same is the same this is the
same
there's gold here but it's the same
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
minecraft hope you enjoyed it I did new
nether update is banging slamming I'm
gonna go see you in the next video bye
bye
[Music]